what's up guys we are punk minutes with
us today we have football specialist
lassi horskainen oh nice and to
celebrate the euro 2020 we're combining
ping pong with football let's go throw
it up
[Music]
let's go through the calls
[Music]
i don't have a good feeling about this
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
can you do that with the football yes
give me a bigger ball
[Music]
[Music]
time to go through the hoop
easy i just will just throw it too
you're sure yeah yeah yeah okay
typical
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's see crossbar challenge
[Music]
let's go a little bit further away
[Music]
okay that's it time for some doubles
absolutely
here's the racket
don't need one thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
level three yeah show me
[Music]
[Music]
okay you can decide you're level three
yeah okay where's your car
[Music]
why
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
huge thanks for joining us today leslie
absolutely i was so impressed we were
able to come up with so many tricks
combining these two sports what do you
think yeah let us know what was your
favorite hey flash shot go live go wide
go okay okay let's go go go
i was so ready for something